[Musique]
événement capital de la semaine 850
journalistes de la presse française et
internationale se trouvait réunis à
l'Élysée pour la conférence de presse du
général de Gaulle qui a évoqué les
conditions de l'entrée de la
Grande-Bretagne dans le marché comme
alors il est possible
qu'un jour
l'Angleterre
parviennent à substance
pour faire partie de la Communauté
européenne sans restriction sans réserve
et préférence à quoi que je fais
et dans ce cas-là les 6 nouvelles à la
porte
répondante au président Kennedy et à son
offre de participation à une force
atomique multinationale le général de
Gaulle rappelait que la France entend
avoir un propre sa défense nationale
dans le monde personne dans le monde et
en particulier personne en Amérique ne
peut
comment dans quelle mesure
les armements nucléaires américains
seraient employé
à défendre l'Europe nous nous en tenons
à la décision que nous avons arrêté
construit et le cas échéant employé
nous-même
notre force atomique
au thermomètre à Paris les pigeons qui
ne trouvèrent plus une goutte d'eau et
les automobilistes auxquelles leur
moteur ont donné chaud en ont été les
premières victimes
la troisième vague de froid de cet hiver
a de nouveau gelé le lac du bois de
Boulogne où il a fallu casser la glace
pour les canards
sur le canal Saint-Martin les péniches
ont été immobilisées mais Paris n'a pas
eu le privilège des basses températures
toute la France ou presque a été logée à
la même enseigne
des spectacles de rêve mais des routes
difficiles
des centaines de péniches bloqués sur
tous les canaux du Nord et de l'Est
Dunkerque aura pour sa part battu une
espèce de record sous un vin glacé de
thermomètre est descendu à moins 15 le
port de pêche a été totalement bloqué et
la mère devant Malo-les-Bains s'est
transformée en banquise la mère du Nord
gelée ce n'était pas jusqu'ici un
spectacle courant mais il risque de le
devenir puisque d'aucun promette à
l'Europe des hivers aussi rigoureux
jusqu'en l'an 2000
[Musique]
malgré la vague de froid qui s'est vite
actuellement aux États-Unis le sourire
de la Joconde a réchauffé le cœur des
Américains qui ont assisté le 8 janvier
dernier en présence du président et de
Madame Jacqueline Kennedy à la
présentation du chef-d'oeuvre de Léonard
de Vinci à la nationale galerie de
Washington
présenté par Monsieur André Malraux le
ministre français des Affaires
Culturelles la mortelle au regard divin
a conquis d'un sourire le président des
États-Unis
et là aussi conquis la foule américaine
qui était si nombreuse que chaque
visiteur n'a disposait que de quelques
secondes pour l'admirer
un Katanga Moïse chombay joue toujours
au chat et à la souris avec les Nations
Unies après s'être enfui une première
fois en rondésie du Sud le président qui
attendait
à retourner dans sa capitale Elisabeth
ville le 10 janvier dernier
à peine arrivé dans son palais il était
mis quelque temps en résidence
surveillée il devait se faire acclamer
avant de disparaître à nouveau
[Applaudissements]
certains ont vu avec soulagement l'homme
s'évadait d'une terre devenue trop
petite qui pour nous nourrir une
humanité dont la moitié est
sous-alimentée et que sera quand la
population 3 milliards aujourd'hui ce
sera encore un truc
c'est oublier un peu vite que les
nourritures terrestres sont loin d'être
toutes exploitées à leur rendement
maximum et c'est aussi faire peu
confiance au progrès des expériences
multiples ont déjà été tentés on est
allé jusqu'à explorer les effets de la
musique sur la croissance des plantes
mes top préconisée par certains savants
de l'âme
[Musique]
mangrait-on un jour de terre arabe les
expériences de Gif-sur-Yvette ont montré
qu'on pouvait d'obtenir des rendements
saisissants en salaire s'inter du tout
quant aux pommes de terre excédentaires
ne riradiation dans une pile atomique
peut nous les conserver des années sans
altération
à son sur les initiatives de bricolage
sur commande est aujourd'hui dépassée
par la production des poussins à
l'échelle véritablement industriels
quant au docteur Bombard il avait montré
les ressources considérables du plancton
marin se méconnu
et voici que le pétrole nous promet bien
davantage les quatre saisons des tankers
modernes pourraient à elle seule nourrir
des régions entières après un certain
traitement toutefois cette espèce de
miracle dont on n'a pas fini de parler
ces produits dans cette raffinerie de la
Vera
dans des ballons sans cesse agités et
aéré à 32 degrés une pincée de bactéries
mélangée à du pétrole le transforme non
protéines autrement dit on bifteck ni
plus ni moins un bifteck qui aurait
l'apparence soit d'un liquide couleur de
café soit d'une poudre jaunâtre
[Musique]
un bifteck qui aurait un goût de fromage
aigre ou de levure mais parfaitement
nourrissant comme le vrai
adieu Amar à l'armoricaine adieu foie
gras à l'heure de midi le retérien de
demain n'aura plus qu'à vider son
éprouvette en 10 secondes on sent
combien le rendement il gagnera
[Musique]
il fait froid dans les tribunes mais pas
sur le terrain du moins pour le moment
et l'équipe de France encore pleine de
dynamisme attaque avec chaleur et muzel
les écossais qui n'en croient pas leurs
yeux
et c'est ainsi que ce produit le premier
miracle du match le drop d'André Bonita
cela ne paraît pas tellement injuste
cependant les boules d'ozeurs écossais
attendent leur heure ils ont le vent
contre eux ils le savent ils ne veulent
pas gâcher leur force avant la seconde
mi-temps
ils sont sans inquiétude même lorsque
Pierre albala des joachent trois points
de plus sur coup franc à l'active des
Français
vous allez voir ce que vous allez voir
messieurs les Français quand nous aurons
le vent dans le dos à notre tour disent
les Écossais de fait dès le début de la
deuxième mi-temps un frissonne dans
l'équipe de France d'abord parce qu'on a
froid il fait maintenant moins 7 degrés
ensuite parce que les Écossais sont
mettre du thé vert les cosses marquent
trois points sur coup franc c'est le
commencement de la fin malgré quelques
belles réactions la troisième ligne
française
et avant de réussir fort justement à
laisser transformer à l'ultime minute du
match l'Ecosse avait entre temps marqué
3 autres points résultat 11 à 6 pour les
écossais
le petit français cette saison prend un
départ sur les chapeaux de roue c'est
d'abord le triomphe les bébés skieurs de
la Grindelwald Marielle watchel en tête
la petite française ne connaît qu'une
chose lorsqu'elle est sur ses skis elle
pense comme un garçon dont elle a le ski
de l'efficacité et quand elle le désire
vraiment aucune de ses concurrentes lui
résiste pas même la championne du monde
l'Autrichienne Marianne et Marielle
gratte-ciel gagne ainsi le premier grand
slalom géant de la saison
[Musique]
pour Émile Biola la descente du Lovera
on a Wengen en Suisse alémanique c'est
exactement la répétition des
championnats du monde de l'an dernier à
Chamonix Viola est un fonceur il prend
des risques pour essayer de vaincre
l'invattable opticien car le train comme
un chamonie va terminer ce gonfle et il
aurait peut-être pu gagner s'il n'avait
pas cherché à forcer un peu trop le
destin
dans cette descente du loberang a
beaucoup fait penser à son compatriote
toniceller quant à niceller il y a
quelques années je pense à surclasser
tous ces adversaires il est précis
efficace souffle et puissant il y a des
jambes d'acier à l'arrivée il a plus de
4 secondes d'avance sur Viola
[Musique]
maintenant le plus extraordinaire du
lover-house c'est le retour à la surface
de celui que l'on attendait plus Guy
Perry il y a 2 ans il était le meilleur
skieur du monde depuis plus rien ou
presque sans rien dire cette année
presque confidentiellement il a pris le
départ du loveroun avec le désir de
gagner c'est maintenant chose faite une
victoire sans discussion dans l'islalom
et la première place du combiné
[Musique]